after everything we're hearing about
spider-man everything seems likely
yeah anything seems likely now the fact
that they got
other movie properties and like that's
incon that's working with
sony that they were able to do this with
spider-man they own
fox yeah do whatever they want
with past characters from other movies
yeah they can do whatever they want
[Music]
what's happening here reject nation greg
and john here today here's the original
plan
was that i've worked till like four in
the morning i'm working on something a
little special for you guys and i have
to wait for the right time to release it
but you guys will probably like it when
it's out anywho
all right i'll sleep in so that way john
and i can meet up in the evening to
cover loki so we'll like cover some
patreon stuff around like 7 p.m then
we'll hop in a loki at midnight and then
pull an all-nighter
all right that was the plan when i
briefly woke up to go to the bathroom
went on social media
i was immediately like what
what is this what is what's going on the
multiverse is opening up
that's what's going on so john swing by
for 15 minutes will you have to do this
really quick how quickly can you get
here
so i looked further into it and i got
some thoughts on this so basically what
ended up happening yesterday because
richard donner sadly passed away i'm a
huge fan
of the lethal weapon franchise a major
fan of the weapon franchise i i love
all of them i mean richard donner rest
in peace i heard he was ill for a while
it's amazing films of guys
superman yeah all right filmmaking
legend he executive produced
the first x-men movie okay okay so there
was this photo that went up
that hugh jackman first he like added to
his i don't remember the order of events
of how he did it but he
he put in his story the boss logic
wolverine poster which looks awesome
boss logic who sometimes works directly
like with the studios sometimes when
boss logic does something people
immediately go oh does this mean
something does this actually mean
something legit but sometimes it's just
fan art that he's doing right then he
shared a photo with him and feige which
immediately the second you do that
[Music]
yeah right he would be naive to think
that the people would not
jump to the entire internet and
especially in the same similar
time frame of posting stories you post a
wolverine claw and then you post one
with feige immediately people are
are going to jump to that conclusion
right a lot of people are thinking that
this means that maybe hugh jackman will
indeed be coming back
to somehow play wolverine in the mcu i'd
like him to make an appearance to say
the least i'd like him to make like at
least
an appearance and when i was like going
okay or the richard donner thing okay
maybe this is in
in tribute to that he did make his own
post that was attributing richard donner
specifically
because to me i like posting that photo
with kevin feige could be like i
wouldn't have met
this man feige if we didn't work
together on x-men way back then in which
richard donner produced sure but the
but the post itself of sharing that
photo does not make you
think or there's anything really text
wise that has you going
oh this is this photo they sharing with
feige is in reference to richard
donner's passing right make you think of
richard donner whatsoever
no i'm like i don't really think it's
about that and some people are actually
saying that
i don't know maybe he's just sharing a
post let's not forget back then he did
funny videos
with ryan reynolds for deadpool and then
sometimes he still does videos with ryan
reynolds nearly every single time he
does people are going is he going to be
in the next deadpool movie is he
never is so it could just be something
that he was
sharing but with all the multiverse
things opening up as of late
knowing when you know the fact that
feige has worked with
hugh jackman on the x-men movies and and
the fact that pretty much
feige got his producing career really
started
with that first he was associate
producer on x-men
launch with them hugh jackman launched
with x-men it would be kind of a cool
nostalgic blend of not just the fact
that you're getting
you know hugh jackman as wolverine in
the mcu to even just make an appearance
perhaps in doctor strange multiverse of
madness
but it just would be neat that those two
get an opportunity
to come back and like do something
together timely yes yeah
on a property adjacent to what gave them
both these
massive you know household name world
spanning careers you know and it's
also too i mean hugh jackman has been on
the record saying like you know the only
way he'd consider
donning the clause again is if it was in
the mcu for some reason
he's got to know that we know that and
if he ever posts a picture of the two of
them that's going to immediately be the
assumption
and now with the multiverse it just
seems more logistically
possible than ever and we do know that
that whole interview that
patrick stewart did where he was saying
that he had talked with feige about
coming back to make an appearance as
professor x in some capacity so i'm sure
the conversations have at least been had
with hugh jackman i'm just like
well dude if you jackman's posting this
it's got to allude to
my i'm quick to jump to it's it has to
allude to something
it's not nothing maybe it is just with
the i wouldn't have met feige
and we wouldn't be where we are today if
it wasn't for this man richard donner
right here who
who helped get x-men off the ground
right maybe but the post doesn't really
seem to indicate that with everything
we're hearing about like spider-man no
way home and then about the villains
that are already confirmed to return and
then
whoever else we're hearing about that
seems very likely they'll be in it and
then with them doing multiverse of
madness and and then even having some
fun teases
even to the extent of having evan peters
appear
as ralph but having you think it's
pietro
in one division right i think it would
be great if hugh jackman does
make a cameo in here i don't think he's
gonna do something
he's like in his 50s now yeah i mean the
thing is if he were to come back i can't
imagine him just signing on for
indefinite more x-men movies or
something yeah because even though he's
super fit and i'm sure he could handle
a certain amount of them yeah he is
getting older and he has sent off the
character in a very heartfelt and very
emotionally invested way
so i feel like that's gotta mean
something to him too so even if he were
to
appear in the mcu you know he's not
gonna be tom holland's mentor in the
next spider-man movie and then the
leader of the avengers or something but
i could see him
having a presence while also allowing
for the ascent of a new wolverine
exactly because he said he would show up
it was like an avengers movie or
something
now multiverse of madness because that's
where my mind is assuming
that's what this project would be
leading towards yeah but if that's the
case it would have already been shot by
now right because i i don't know if
they're done
filming or if they're close to done
filming because for sure they've been
they were filming way back when one
division was airing i don't know
where they're at production wise in
terms of filming if he is in it
for even a little bit i'm assuming that
role that's already been shot
yeah that's where my mind would go
that's already been done my point being
is that multiverse of madness is
sounding like it's gonna be a crossover
event
regardless so maybe it might not be
directly an avengers title
movie however it's still a crossover
event film
i feel like he would want to at least if
he has an opportunity to participate in
that where it's not something where he
has to physically exhaust himself yeah
yeah yeah i think he would do it
and if it is some type of like other
multiverse wolverine
and not the logan who departed i'd be
down i i would be dead
it's not the same thing as like yeah
bring him back and undercut what
happened in logan it's not the same
thing to me well and we've established
through the mcu multiverse that yeah you
can
have variants of a certain character
that look remarkably like that character
in variants that look completely
different so i don't think it would even
be that distracting with the idea yes
that eventually we'll get another
wolverine down the line or something and
yeah something like multiverse of
madness where like it's the title it's
the whole point is like we're gonna be
hopping around a lot of worlds and
seeing a lot of characters
that could be yeah a really fun nod and
a good one in a timely sense like it
seems like if hugh jackman's gonna show
up it needs to happen sooner rather than
later yeah
and that seems like the best opportunity
coming up for sure well guys
what do you think about this news do you
think hugh jackman meant anything by it
do you think people are blowing it out
of proportion
do you think he actually will make a
cameo in the mcu leave your thoughts
down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button and
hey we'll catch you guys soon